oyentes y cyber seguidores de radio
canadá internacional bienvenidos a su
programa semanal canadá en las américas
café el castor cibernético los saluda
paloma martínez y aquí en el estudio no
hay mucha gente pero somos pocos pero
los podemos lo mejor
des podemos rápidamente desear un
maravilloso año a la gente es el primer
programa de la mano
estaban muy adelantados felicidades a ti
personas nos escuchan también y qué
maravilla el 2010 y no yo tengo es que
cada vez que empieza un año tengo
esperanzas de que cosas buenas pasen y
siempre pasan cosas buenas a pesar de
las cosas malas me encontré con
muchísima gente que decía al fin se
terminó el 2008 personalmente en lo
personal por supuesto no fue para nada
malo
de esta manera para ser diplomático pero
bueno ha comenzado otro año más así que
la posibilidad de recomenzar desde cero
de plantearse nuevos objetivos y de
tener la esperanza de que todo va a ir
mejor
bueno vuelven a hacer presión es mi hijo
que ahora es adolescente y está
cuestionando todo me decía porque
tenemos que cambiar de año porque
tenemos que hacer fiesta de fin de año
porque hindús me puse a reflexionar y
dije todo a través de la historia y le
gusta mucho la historia la historia y
con eso lo convencí que los seres
humanos siempre hacemos marcamos el
tiempo no hay que marcar el tiempo
porque si no eso es una convención pero
una convención que ayuda a ponerse metas
hay una vez escuché una explicación con
un tema negra vamos a entrar en detalle
porque no es el presupuesto agradable
pero es el tema de la muerte
y un filósofo estadounidense explicaba
el valor de la muerte desde un punto de
vista si uno quiere entre comillas
positivo y es el hecho de que sabiendo
que nos vamos a morir sabiendo que
tenemos un punto final al que nos
dirigimos eso nos ayuda o nos debería
ayudar en todo caso a plantearnos
conseguir metas antes de que ese punto
final llegue si la gente fuese eterna y
supiera que es eterna para que
preocuparse por los temas cotidianos
para que trabajar para
limpiar la casa para que pintar un
ambiente o lo que uno quisiera hacer yo
creo que es una manera como los
cumpleaños como el cambio de temporada
como todos los tonos las celebraciones
que van marcando digamos los momentos
distintos del año y aquí en canadá
sentimos las temporadas cambiar me
parece que eso es algo que me ha servido
a mí digamos para organizar mi tiempo es
un fusible es un fusible que permite
hacer saltar el fusible que ya no
queríamos seguir utilizando y recomenzar
exactamente bueno hoy en el programa no
trataremos de la entrada del año porque
ya pasó ya estamos avanzados en 2019
para nosotros cuando llegue a trabajar
ayer comencé a trabajar de nuevo ayer
después de los días de descanso otros
colegas ya tenían ahí varios días
incluyéndote a ti
hablábamos de convenciones presión y por
ejemplo el tema del famoso la famosa
de fin de año solemos hacer la mayoría
de las personas no sé si todas las
manillas
nosotros nos juntamos con un matrimonio
conocido pero a las 10 y yo pensaba irme
a las 10 me fui a las 11 a trabajar y
aquí hay que estar temprano y uno quiere
estar más temprano incluso de lo que
debería a eso de permitirse más y bueno
yo me recordó el tema de la convención
hasta en eso está en las cenas y hay que
esperar que brindamos y claro es verdad
en este año hicimos reunión pero en
pequeño en la casa con los con los hijos
con los con el marido y nada más y luego
nos quedamos pensando pero vamos a lo
visto con tu marido
qué quiere decir esto no lo que quiere
decir es que no había otros amigos
estábamos cada noche nos sentamos a
comer pero esta vez lo hicimos especial
y todo pero nada más nosotros cuatro
para celebrar y dijimos bueno por qué no
celebrar nosotros había otros amigos que
no querían venir que no podían en mi
mamá está en méxico mi hermano está en
méxico dijeron nosotros celebramos y
estuvo lindo también el sol bueno
entonces esta semana en el programa
tenemos temas lunares
clima climáticos no hemos decidido que
no hablamos del clima no nieve
exactamente pero sabes que louis esta
semana hablaremos de nuestros oyentes
porque generalmente no los mencionamos
tanto tenemos que mencionarlos mal hoy
bajó más hoy vamos a leer muchas cartas
vamos a ponernos ese objetivo qué te
parece un objetivo para esta emisión ya
ni siquiera para el año para hoy
nuestras resoluciones son día con día
comencemos con la luna
[Música]
hola mi nombre es mariló núñez y soy la
directora artística de alameda tiro el
campo ni aquí en toronto los invito a
escuchar canadá en las américas café el
programa de radio canadá internacional
en la web
louis entonces faltaba un t
entonces luis esta semana ayer
justamente fue una primicia mundial el
primer equipo de 'las no de astronautas
tipo espacial del mundo logró instalar
en la luna una sonda y tomar fotos
tenemos algunas imágenes que estarán
probablemente la gente viendo hasta
ahora las imágenes y los colores que
corresponden esos colores pero bueno
digamos que nuestros oyentes están
viendo los colores correctos de todos
modos la idea es que por primera vez en
la historia de la humanidad llegaron al
lado oscuro de la luna lo cual es
extraordinario me gustaría que mi colega
que está acá que es nuestro colega de
dimes del equipo chino pudiera
establecernos un poco más de detalle
sobre esto pero no habla español pero
pero ya estamos enseñando ya le estamos
enseñando entonces estamos mostrando las
imágenes increíbles no me parece
increíble en la agencia espacial china
ha puesto por primera vez como vos
acabas de decir una
nave en el lado oscuro de la luna que
hasta el momento aparecía como
mayormente desconocido por parte de los
terrícolas vamos a decir en esos
términos es decir a la luna se ha
llegado sabemos todos recordamos todos
los que tenemos llegar suficiente para
recordarlo en todo caso el famoso
alunizaje del año 69 primera vez el
hombre pudo poner un pie sobre la luna
pero siempre desde él desde la cara que
vemos desde la tierra siempre esa esa
cara que la luna nos muestra sabemos que
tiene la luna movimiento de rotación que
hace que te muestre a la tierra siempre
el mismo mismo esto o la misma cara la
misma el mismo lado efectivamente pero
no se había llegado a poder explorar en
el lugar pisando el lado oscuro de la
luna y esta es la primera vez que una
misión de la agencia espacial china ha
logrado poner una nave que todavía no
sabemos bien cómo llamar así es change
for change 4 o como pero ahora vamos a
descubrir cómo change for me suena ching
y está si ese es uno de palabras
apelando precisamente al
ahora el cambio en inglés activamente a
la construcción del nombre en chino y
está nave va a llevar a cabo distintos
procesos distintos distintas etapas de
exploración entre ellas recoger muestras
de ese lado oculto de la luna para
presumiblemente poder obtener mayor
información sobre el origen del universo
salió de la tierra el 8 de diciembre y
ahora aterrizó el mismo día a las 10 26
pero apenas ayer pudimos comenzar a
obtener ayer ayer 3 de enero pudimos
comenzar a ver las primeras primeras
imágenes que fueron liberadas entonces
por la agencia espacial china increíble
yo creo porque por mucho tiempo digamos
el lado oscuro de la luna siempre ha
sido como algo misterioso no y ahora lo
interesante es que además de esto
anunciaron también que no solamente
están llevando esta zona sonda perdón
que establecieron ahí que pusieron que
alunizaron en esta región de la luna
sino que además probablemente en los en
las próximas décadas
establecerán una estación espacial sobre
la luna para seguir para seguir
investigando siempre visto hacer más
misiones en la misión
chang 5 prevista para el futuro no hay
una fecha decidida aún todavía y además
en china también tiene previsto enviar
una misión pero ya tripulada con con
gente que va que podría descender en ese
lado oculto de la luna en el año 2036
donde estaremos en el 2036 vuelve aquí y
aquí haciendo este programa nos queda
mucho por trabajar todavía así que por
qué no acabamos de programas y de futuro
y de programas de futuro sigamos los
programas a larga distancia en este caso
pero no volviendo a hablar simplemente
el tema en el 2036 entonces china piensa
poner una misión tripulada en la fas
oculta de la luna y esto que os decía
recién lo de construir una base
permanente ha creado alguna
a falta de alguna confusión y algún
enojo y alguna molestia pues a mí a mí
cuando lo escuché me llamó la atención
porque en realidad dije pero qué derecho
tiene una nación cualquiera que ésta sea
china o eeuu o rusia cualquier otra que
derecho tiene una nación de establecer
una colonia en un lugar que no pertenece
a nadie bueno si es de tipo científica
digamos
y que va a aportar datos como para todo
el mundo efectivamente bienvenida sea
pero aportarán datos para todo el mundo
guardaran datos bueno eso quién lo
podría saber lo cierto pero también en
la misma discusión que ocurre por
ejemplo en otro plano con el tema de la
antártida
que se puede instalar allí y nadie puede
reclamar territorio porque supuestamente
es un continente que pertenece a toda la
humanidad pero sabemos que hay misiones
incluso militares también significa
acciones militares que tienen bases en
la antártida y supuestamente toda la
información que se recoge allí es
compartida en buenos términos con todos
los otros países
pensemos en que en la luna va a ocurrir
lo mismo pensemos que si ahora la
agencia china y la agencia espacial
china también dijo que eventualmente
después de después de la luna vendrá a
marte y establecerán colonias pero
colonias de investigación científica
también pero bueno china hasta el
momento aparecía relegado en la carrera
espacial está recuperando el espacio de
manera muy acelerada están de alguna
manera relanzando la carrera espacial
porque sabemos también que eeuu tuvo
problemas durante muchos años para
proseguir con sus programas espaciales
de hecho hace años que eeuu no intenta
llegar nuevamente a la luna habiendo
colocado ya un nombre allí en el año 69
como decíamos hace un rato y
china vuelve a lanzar esta idea de
llegar a la luna no solamente apunta
también a marte como vos decías así que
tal vez eso genere una nueva competencia
entre estados unidos china y por qué no
algún otro país para poder relanzar de
manera más fuerte son como las potencias
las potencias mundiales espaciales
serían eeuu rusia y ahora parece que
china en tan bueno y márton en lo que
pasa que figuran menos en la india
también ha hecho sus experiencias en los
últimos años recordemos el plan espacial
europeo que durante mucho tiempo también
se presente y que luego también por
problemas sobre todo financieros quedó
en suspenso pero no habría que descartar
que vuelvan una y la canadiense que
participada a pequeña escala pero con
cosas importantes no siempre hemos
hablado aquí en el programa del brazo
canadiense que forma parte que es un
brazo robótico es gigante que sirve para
cosas extraordinarias y dificilísimas en
la base en la estación espacial
internacional y bueno los astronautas
entre otros
ya que está ahora en la estación
espacial internacional entonces hay
colaboraciones internacionales en los
proyectos que son digamos más y que uno
piensa que son más de la nasa
específicamente pero son internacionales
a agencia espacial canadiense que tiene
sucede muy suavecito y cerca de sí
atravesando el puente sí y en la
república de la ribera sur de ese
territorio soberano al que pertenecemos
unos pocos así tiene su sede la agencia
espacial canadiense y un dato más que te
quería agregar el nombre este nombre de
que dudamos de la misión o como de dónde
viene este nombre
es un homenaje a una diosa que china que
según cuenta las leyendas vive en la
luna o me anda saber si esta misión
entonces no fue una misión cuyo objetivo
principal entidad es encontrar el rostro
de esa diosa
seguimos entonces aquí en canadá en las
américas café el castor cibernético
[Música]
hola mi nombre es luis alberto garcía
soy cubano actor director productor
destino cubano estoy de visita a ottawa
les mando un saludo a todos los oyentes
y los invito a escuchar canadá en las
américas café el programa sabatino de
radio para la internacional en la web ya
no están sabatino este programa pero
seguimos en la web en sólo semanas se
pueden escuchar cuando quieran y estamos
difundiendo por youtube por nuestro
sitio internet por facebook así que
están ustedes en facebook o en youtube y
quieren comentar algo en directo ahorita
nos estamos conectando para que podamos
ver quién nos está escribiendo y louis
antes de seguir justamente leyendo los
mensajes de los oyentes y otras cosas me
gustaría que nos presentáramos uno de
tus temas de la semana porque tú
trabajaste mucho
existe varios temas interesantes y
elegiste uno para presentarlo a nuestros
oyentes si es una entrevista que hicimos
un artista que ya había entrevistado en
una ocasión anterior y no solamente yo
otros miembros del equipo también que es
josé luís torres es un artista plástico
de origen argentino pero que reside hace
ya muchísimos años aquí en canadá y él
en el transcurso del 2018 que ya se fue
que les pasado realizó tres exposiciones
todas con el mismo tema todas dedicadas
en todo caso al mismo sujeto que es el
de la inmigración en estas tres
exposiciones tuvieron a la inmigración
como tema central en un año en el que la
inmigración fue un tema presente en
tanto en canadá como en el plano
internacional recordemos las olas
migratorias que siguen incluso en las
últimas horas llegando a langostas en
europa recordemos el tema de la
inmigración que recuperó también nos un
lado más positivo sino la cuestión
conflictiva a partir de la caravana de
inmigrantes provenientes
los países de américa central que
intentó ingresar en eeuu y luego pasando
por méxico también siendo un causa y
efectivamente muchos de ellos permanecen
aún en méxico esperando tener la ocasión
de ingresar ese territorio al que ven
aún a pesar de todos los problemas como
supo sidad de futuro y por supuesto en
un tema presente siempre presente en
canadá que tiene una población compuesta
en algún grado importante por
inmigrantes josé luis torres retomó el
tema de la inmigración en tres
exposiciones que se llevan a cabo en
ontario en quebec y en alberta y en el
país
y siempre con
[Música]
una visión e intenta ser positiva en
este caso retoma tres temáticas que él
señala como centrales dentro del tema de
inmigración que es la reconstrucción la
redefinición porque porque el inmigrante
intenta o debe en todo caso redefinirse
todo el tiempo busca nuevos horizontes
busca un destino mejor busca mejores
posibilidades de vida y para eso tiene
que cambiar de hábitat cambiar de
geografía cambiarse a sí mismo
redefinirse porque sabemos que llegar a
una nueva sociedad implica nuevos
desafíos implica nuevas metas implica
nuevas circunstancias y eso conlleva a
una nueva persona también si se puede
decir entre comillas entonces para poder
apuntar a poder aspirar a tener éxito en
la nueva sociedad es necesario dejar
algo del pasado atrás y abrazar algo de
lo nuevo de eso que se encuentra en la
nueva sociedad el habla de un cambio
perpetuo
qué es verdad se expresa en esto que
acabamos de decir y retoma también la
noción del inmigrante como el nómade y
el humano de por sí tiene una naturaleza
nómade fue nómade durante mucho tiempo
hasta que luego con la revolución
industrial y con otras cuestiones que
hacen las revoluciones agrícolas de esta
descripción agrícola por supuesto
obviamente antes que la industrial e
hicieron que el ser humano se asentase
en un lugar pero la idea de buscar un
mejor futuro no la perdió sigue presente
y entonces esas inmigración es que
ocurren hoy en día que recuperan ese rol
de nómade miguel dice que bueno que la
naturaleza cambiante es propia del ser
humano y la redefinición es propia del
ser humano por eso apela a imágenes en
estas exposiciones no se vieron filas de
inmigrantes o gente tratando de cruzar
la frontera sino objetos que en
principio nada tienen que ver con
medidas y algunas
es como una casa rodante cortada para
que pueda ver como el cambio de gama es
una casa rodante que en principio puede
llevar a pensar en un turista y que no
es un turista ese es el inmigrante que
viaja todo el tiempo buscando su destino
y esa casa rodante es redefinida también
en esa búsqueda de un nuevo destino y
tenemos un extracto de la entrevista que
es tips que tuviste con él lo escuchamos
entonces como
hay que tener en cuenta que nosotros
también como inmigrantes contribuimos al
desarrollo a la evolución de cada uno de
los lugares que nos albert es común en
siete negociación nosotros tenemos que
liberarnos que algunas elementos que
tienen que ver con nuestro nuestras
tierras ahorita tenemos que saber
conciliar con eso no podemos encontrar
lo mismo que dejamos en este nuevo lugar
al liberar ese no ganamos pero al mismo
tiempo
también dejamos yo creo que eso es
importante terminarlo en mente siempre
porque nos ayuda justamente en el
proceso de adaptación tanto tejanos como
tanto incorporan
entonces era josé luis torres artista
visual que estuvo presentando como nos
decías en el 2018
estas tres expo es en tres lugares
distintos que retomaban el tema de la
inmigración de la movilidad humana
digamos que es algo tan natural que
conocemos también nosotros
[Risas]
geografías vamos a andar en otros en
futuro y que cada vez nos re definimos
como decía así que nos identificamos y
que no es tu identidad de alguna manera
se va modificando y va cambiando con el
tiempo y con el espacio también no ser
bueno y yo les presentó esta semana un
tema que es menos agradable pero que me
pareció que era importante tocarlo
porque fue una colaboración que tuvimos
con el equipo de civis y que es la red
inglesa de radio canadá vinieron a
buscarnos porque resultó resulta que
surgió una noticia en los medios
dominicanos y a partir de la policía
nacional dominicana como que un
canadiense fue arrestado y
posteriormente liberado en república
dominicana por presunto intento de
agresión sexual a una niña de siete
voy a pedirle a mi colega que nos
pasemos al otro tema justamente porque
nos da la imagen de este canadiense su
nombre es ibón joseph louis lingg o de
nosotros es un presunto acusado en este
momento fue liberado por las por las
autoridades dominicanas porque la
investigación sigue en curso pero no ha
habido una denuncia oficial en su contra
ni en contra del padre de la niña que
tiene 7 años porque supuestamente en el
centro de la información que se tiene
hasta el momento el padre habría dado su
consentimiento para el contacto entre
este canadiense y la pequeñita entonces
bueno todo está sobre todo es son
suposiciones por el momento porque no
hay ninguna prueba actualmente pero la
investigación sigue en curso y nos
parece importante hablar del tema
estuvimos en comunicación con la
sargento rosario del carmen garcía de la
policía nacional
de república dominicana en puerto plata
en particular y tuvimos la conversar con
ella para que nos explicar un poco la
situación entonces les presento un
extracto de la entrevista con ella llamó
para tener información sobre el
canadiense que fue detenido el 31 de
diciembre pasado el señor ivonne joseph
ghislain gods
yo sé quién es el descuento pero
entonces se sigue investigando porque la
fiscalidad ha sacado con su celular y
con su computadora para seguir
investigando pero lo soltaron los
soltaron y por qué lo soltaron
los soltaron porque las familiares de la
niña no se dejaron no hay nadie que
ponga una denuncia
[Música]
entonces si la madre de la niña la madre
de la niña falleció y ella solamente
tiene a su papá y una hermana mayor pero
el hermano mayor hizo a pelearse contra
de su papá y del canadiense
entiendo
entonces pero la policía sigue
investigando
en conjunto con la fiscalidad sigan
investigando el caso de acuerdo pero
esta niña la niña está en un lugar que
le llaman aquí con annie
un hogar para niños para niños en
peligro
de acuerdo y entonces pero no se sabe si
el extranjero este extranjero se quedó
allá o se volvió a canadá no no el
extranjero sigo aquí todavía porque
estaba cierto tiempo lo van a estar
llamando
claro no se puede ir y alguna otra
información que me pueda dar sargento
sobre este sobre este caso en particular
no sea algo que por qué estoy llamando
aquella y hay varios ciudadanos
canadienses que nos han pedido que
investiguemos un poquito qué está
pasando con este caso el médico
creció la niña y la están esperando los
resultados del inacif pero no hasta
tanto no hay nada mal de acuerdo le
agradezco mucho porque con quien tengo
el gusto perdón con la sargento mayor
garcía la encargada de relaciones
públicas en la dirección regional norte
usuario del carmen y yo hablé con paloma
martínez soy periodista en radio canadá
paloma mar
no sé
rosario le agradezco mucho vamos a
seguir la investigación no hay problema
mi amor estamos a la disposición bueno
le agradezco muchísimo rosario
aunque hay gracias igual
entonces bueno versación que tuvimos con
la sargento rosario del carmen garcía de
la policía nacional de república
dominicana con respecto al arresto y a
la liberación de este ciudadano
canadiense ivonne joseph ghislain goudet
entonces bueno vamos a seguir
esperando más información porque bueno
el reporte preliminar del caso refiere a
que el padre de la menor le había
llevado a la habitación del hotel en
donde fue arrestado el señor la policía
nacional precisó que mientras estuvieron
detenidos los hombres estuvieron bajo el
control del ministerio público y bueno
el diario electrónico puerto plata
puerto digital perdón puerto plata
digital entrevistó al fiscal titular de
puerto plata osvaldo bonilla hiraldo
quien habría dicho al medio informativo
que los dos ciudadanos investigados
fueron puestos en libertad luego de que
médicos legistas y ginecólogos además de
psicólogos evaluaron a la menor y
determinaron que se encuentra en
perfectas condiciones de todos modos
ella nos decía la sargento que las
informaciones más detalladas del de los
médicos todavía estamos esperándolos
a finales de los estudios entonces bueno
esto es una es una historia que sigue
que sigue continuo que continúa digamos
así que bueno seguiremos si además es un
tema complicado que hay que tratar con
mucho cuidado cuando se trata de una
menor de por medio de armas en el caso
de presuntos abusos sexuales sabemos las
implicancias que esto puede tener no
habido acusación como decía la persona
que entrevistas que eso puede llegar a
complicar un poco la marcha de la causa
pero hasta que no se tenga una voz un
poco más firme lo mejor es esperar
entonces que la justicia siga su camino
tranquilamente y luego veremos qué
resultados que lo que les presentamos
ahora es la información que tenemos por
el momento que eso fue la que nos
otorgaron las las autoridades en
república dominicana entonces
continuamos
sí
tiré de jinhua a politicastros
en la historia del castor en inglés y
francés
[Música]
entonces es el momento de leer cartas y
mensajes de nuestros oyentes y decía yo
que quería ver si había mensajitos que
nos abrían llegada a través de la
difusión en facebook y si efectivamente
tenemos mensajes de manfred echeverría
un fiel oyente de radio canadá
internacional dice saludos amigos feliz
2019 escuchándolos cabe la pregunta
hasta cuándo se debe desear el buen año
en el ecuador lo hacemos hasta el 6 de
enero día de reyes
yo también hasta el 6 de enero después
ya no no encontrase por ejemplo el 10 de
enero una persona que no viste desde que
empezó el año
pero ya es tarde y empezó ya pasó
cuando regrese en pablo russo leonardo
sobre todo si vienen con regalitos les
deseamos ver y cuando tienes razón aquí
hay otro mensajito rapidísimo ariel
rabinovich también en facebook saludos
desde méjico alexandra hernández un
abrazo gigante desde bogotá colombia y
hamlet lombardi desde santa marta
colombia también el país está de duelo
por el sensible fallecimiento de radamel
garcía kings padre de falcao garcía
jugador del mónaco fcc saludos paloma
martínez y luis laborda saludos hamlet
saludos ariel saludos álex alexandra
feliz feliz a nelson contreras dice
nelson contreras rincón también dice
saludos desde barranquilla colombia
feliz año para todo el equipo de radio
canadá internacional muchas gracias a
todos los saludamos no sabemos en qué
cámara están todos otros mensajes por
ahí louis si un mensaje que nos envía
gracia mastología como nuestro habitual
oyente desde buenos aires en argentina
espero que se encuentre muy bien a pesar
de que no escribo tan asiduamente como
quisiera siempre escucho el programa y
visitó la página web de la emisora que
me mantienen informada acerca de los
acontecimientos de canadá y del ámbito
internacional
personalmente esperando las vacaciones
que comienzan en enero luego de un año
muy difícil en todos los sentidos
siempre recuerdo con un poco de
nostalgia aquellos años cuando los
escuchaba por onda corta y realizaba los
informes para la sección reportero de un
día
por medio de este correo quiero
desearles a todos los integrantes del
equipo muy feliz navidad junto a sus
seres queridos y un 2019 pleno de salud
trabajo paz y nuevos proyectos que
puedan realizar un saludo afectuoso a
todos y será hasta pronto dice graciela
más trilogía como desde buenos aires en
argentina gracias gracias a lo que no
entiendo todavía es en el es polo sur
las vacaciones tienen vacaciones de
navidad y bueno las vacaciones en
argentina por lo menos suelen comenzar
suelen comenzar no es que se tengan que
adaptar esas fechas pero la mayoría la
gente la toma entre diciembre enero y
febrero también hay que gastar más
un poco más tarde en las escuelas y las
escuelas comienzan a mediados los fines
de diciembre y de vacaciones hasta el
mes de marzo
de vacaciones de escuela y las clases se
terminan cada vez más tarde y yo creo
que ahora ya están cerca de las últimas
la última o anti última semana de
diciembre pero yo creo pero en mi época
no acepta entonces muy poquito las
clases comenzaban las escribe la segunda
semana y las clases para las vacaciones
comenzaban la segunda semana de
diciembre y se extendían hasta bien
avanzado marzo con lo cual el verano
yo no pues que no me puedo imaginar el
verano en diciembre pero entiendo yo sí
efectivamente otro mensaje tienes para
ello un mensaje que nos envía javier
gonzález nunca hará ahí desde
efectivamente que nos dice hablando del
tema de méxico hay un templo dedicado al
dios xipe tótec
y dice estas investigaciones
descubrimiento se hacen más bonitas e
interesantes todas las tribus
nahuatlacas en méxico está saliendo bien
el náhuatl el bueno y en especial los
aztecas que fueron los más fuertes
saludos a todos en el castor cibernético
iniciando este año 2019
muchas gracias a javier javier gonzález
número muy bien tengo aquí un mensaje
que nos llegó de leclerc suponemos que
es un quebequense porque tiene un nombre
muy de quebec saludo el geely dice era
un comentando digamos el reportaje de un
canadiense vendedor de árboles de
navidad hará el regalo más importante de
su vida y él dice qué hermosa
generosidad impresionante con muchos
signos de admiración y bueno por eso
tenemos que leer todos estos mensajes
porque como estuvimos de vacaciones
bueno aquí dice que ya pasó pero que
dice que no pasó es el mismo mensaje
bueno sigamos por las dudas hasta la
copia la vida también
otro mensaje que nos envía en este caso
ramón sepúlveda es sobre el tema el
español y los adultos mayores en la nada
dice interesante artículo me encantó el
concepto que los entrevistados tienen
del español sí porque es un reportaje un
largo un formato largo que ruffo
presentó sobre las clases de español
para adultos mayores aquí en que ver
word o si es muy lindo este reportaje y
muy lindos testimonios de gente porque
sabemos que hay mucha gente en canadá y
en quebec
que les que les gusta muchísimo estudiar
el español y bueno ahí rufo mostraba
como el español estaba teniendo mucho
éxito entre los adultos mayores también
pica vemos a situaciones concretas sí sí
sí exactamente otro mensaje que tengo
por acá dos instituciones canadienses
ofrecen becas para aprender inglés a
mujeres de américa latina y lo que no
encuentro es la persona que nos escribe
porque dice hola deseo que las
instituciones que ofrecen becas por
favor no coloquen barreras o límites con
la edad
soy una líder social mayor de 50 años
con muchos deseos
a aprender este idioma y poder ayudar y
transmitir este conocimiento a mi
comunidad sobre todo a jóvenes y niños
bastante atropellados por el conflicto
armado en mi municipio miranda
departamento del cauca colombia sur
américa gracias por su atención pero no
dice su nombre bueno entonces si no
dicen su nombre no le podemos ayudar es
un poco difícil pero puede que nos esté
quedando y enviarnos un nombre entonces
un nuevo mensaje exactamente nos encanta
recibir mensajes balones tengo aquí un
mensaje que nos envía este pico lo sobre
el tema eeuu repelió a migrantes que
quisieron traspasar la frontera y ella
da su visión dice hay que hacer lo que
sea necesario para impedir que más de
estas personas indeseables entren a eeuu
bien por la patrulla fronteriza nuestras
oraciones están con los agentes que
cumplen con su deber que se regresen a
sus países esos vagos y se pongan a
trabajar en lugar de venir a exigir que
se les dé de todo aquí es la opinión de
este artículo sobre el tema de la cara
de la caravana de migrantes que quiso
ingresar hace unas semanas atrás ha
estado
si cada quien en su opinión lo que es
cierto es que muchas veces esa gente
viene escapando de situaciones que son
creadas por muchas por otras
particularidades digamos económicas
sociales políticas de que no están al
alcance de esas de esas personas de
cambiarlas y que no tienen suficientes
medios digamos pero bueno tiene tiene
tiene derecho a pensar eso es mal cierre
me di vida nos dice gracias por el
programa amigos de radio canadá
internacional en la escucha semanal
abrazos leonora leonardo rufo y pablo no
nos incluyo no estaríamos tal vez ese
día como
gracias nelsy igual tengo aquí un
mensaje que nos envía rené alexander
martínez sobre el tema neurólogo experto
en epilepsia ofrece consulta gratis en
español desde saskatchewan y dice el
mensaje de rené alexander es correcto
tomar toda esta medicina al día que
recetó la neuróloga me recetó a tomar
cuatro pastillas de 100 miligramos de
según mide y tomar 4 de pronta el cine
de 100 mil miligramos creo que nos está
preguntando a nosotros y es correcto
tomarla
medicación y nosotros mal haríamos en
contradecir la sugerencia de su
especialista y en todo caso a rené al
examen lo que le podemos sugerir es que
devuelva a consultar si es que tiene
alguna duda sobre la medicación que está
tomando sitio si tiene algún síntoma que
le haga dudar de los efectos positivos
de esta medicación pero ni vos ni yo
somos médicos y más daríamos entonces se
encuentra el si la opinión de un experto
exactamente y tengo aquí un mensaje de
jota héctor no da su apellido o tal vez
sector sea su apellido es en algunas
ocasiones ese apellido el tema trudeau
trump y peña nieto- firman nuevo tlcan
en buenos aires y dice interesante el
nombre cusma y así tenemos que
memorizarlo en canadá al nuevo al nuevo
acuerdo más fácil de decir que antes era
como u s me puse me sea más fácil de
decir ahora si vos me decís cusma lo
primero que pienso es un plato de comida
la sopa algo así o de cuscús o algo por
el estilo pero bueno parece que se quedo
cusma en español que hoy no más tengo
mensaje aquí de marco aurelio gómez
forero que se refiere al tema se puede
curar la pedofilia él dice que en mi
concepto del tema del sistema jurídico
debe castigar severamente los actos de
pedofilia y cuando en estos incluye
asesinatos atroces como en muchas
ocasiones ha ocurrido en mi país
colombia debe castigarse con la pena de
muerte de este opinión y marco aurelio
gómez forero u otros comentarios con
respecto al canadiense vendedor de
árboles de navidad que hará un regalo
muy importante de su más el regalo más
importante de su vida
eric dice personas como esta es la que
necesitamos para hacer un mundo mejor
nostalgia da ver como la edad nos va
minando las fuerzas y nos obliga a dejar
de continuar con hermosas tradiciones
dios bendiga a este señor
rogers y también comenta el mismo tema a
alguien más y ya se me perdió la hoja
bueno mira pero hablando sobre el tema
de los árboles de navidad por estos días
se empiezan a verse en las calles de la
ciudad del mismo para en todo en canadá
los famosos árboles naturales tirados
porque sabes voz paloma pero tal vez
nuestros oyentes tal vez no lo sepan
todos que es una tradición muy arraigada
aquí comprar árboles naturales pinos
naturales para armar el famoso árbol de
navidad y en realidad es algo que a mí
no me termina de agradar porque si bien
es muy bonito ver el árbol ahí va
efectivamente una vez que la festividad
pasó y ya estamos apenas a 4 de enero
los árboles son tirados a la carga y
visto cómo están hace tiraditos si me
dan una tristeza de los arbolitos tiran
entonces hay distintas iniciativas entre
ellas algunos municipios de distintas
zonas de aquí de quebec que quieren
imponer ciertas restricciones para el
uso de árboles naturales y además poner
en práctica planes de reciclado de los
parece que ya en algunas municipalidades
la de montreal ya tienen instalado un
programa y utilizan esos árboles para
hacer una vez que los que los recuperan
los compost han o también crean otro
tipo de productos de madera y otras
cosas lo que es cierto es que el otro
día había un proyecto en el que puedes
sembrar un arbolito a principios del año
como ahora sería un buen momento para
empezar vas a sembrar un arbolito a un
lugar pero como dentro de una maceta
grande y entonces sabes que es una
maceta
ok
entonces cool pones a editar bonito lo
ves crecer y entonces al final del año
porque los árboles así de este tipo
crecen rápido si los tienes cuidados en
un cierto ambiente
entonces lo haces crecer y después
cuando llegue a diciembre y mediados de
diciembre lo llevas a tu casa en su
maceta lo decora y lo sigue echando agua
echando
y luego después lo llevas a ese otro
lugar donde lo había sembrado al
principio te lo cuidan todo el año lo
hacen crecer todo el año y al otro año
igual te llevas a casa
tal vez tengan un servicio de camiones
así grandes y digamos por ejemplo diez
años después sigue siendo mi favorito
sigue siendo el mismo árbol que antes
era arbolito tal vez lo llevan después
al al bosque pero no se pierde entonces
te dan ciertas restricciones de cómo lo
de kores para que no se maltrate el
árbol y que puedas
siguiente seguirlo recuperando es una
buena idea voy a investigar las
tradiciones degustar estos árboles
naturales para la navidad yo tengo mi
árbol sintético que usó el mismo desde
hace años y que cada vez cada vez que
llega la fecha correspondiente lo
montamos ahí en casa lo ponemos con
todas sus luces sus adornos
ilumina la alegría la música no tan
alegre y después
con un sonido de campanita de teléfono
celular de mala calidad pero bueno
estallado está allí armado y en pocas
horas más será desarmado también y
guardado para el próximo año y no
dañamos el medio ambiente si no tienes
razón tiene razón tengo otros mensajitos
que llegaron acá al facebook live de
wilmer alberto márquez menezes dice
feliz año a todos los del equipo del pse
y desde el carmen norte de colombia
parece nds colombiano sé que es nds y
luego nelson contreras lo manda a
saludar a wilmer marqués porque su
paisano así que bueno a mucha acción
en facebook hoy por allá y louis tienes
por ahí algo más si yo tengo un mensaje
que nos envía pamela álvarez juárez
sobre el tema médico canadiense dice que
la diabetes tipo 2 es curable dice mi
nombre es pamela de 33 años y tengo
diabetes tipo 2 acaban de decirme hace
un mes la verdad es que cuando me
dijeron sentí morir me pero tengo la
esperanza de que algún día salga la cura
es he estado leyendo sobre el doctor es
que las revierten y me gustaría un día
poder visitarlos para salvar mi vida
pues aún tengo una familia joven bueno
eso también esperamos que puedan
visitarlo si no es así me encontraré en
tu lugar a los médicos que puedan darte
una mano para sobreponerte esta diabetes
que ya pero hoy por hoy no es una
enfermedad tan difícil de tratar como
era hace unas décadas atrás bueno lo es
que crees nos quedamos sin tiempo nos
quedamos sin tiempo ya no los que pensar
las cosas
éramos pocos para no una sola persona
eso sí no se puede entonces alargamos el
espacio para que podemos ir diciendo dos
o más o más entonces muchas gracias a
todos ustedes por habernos seguido en
canadá en las américas café el castor
cibernético aquí en el estudio
estuvieron nuestro bordo paloma martínez
ertzain que está aquí haciendo los
controles técnicos internet y chantal 6
software por los controles técnicos
gracias
feliz semana no
[Música]